[Music]
the upcoming game of thrones prequel
series house of the dragon is based on
the georgia or martin's targaryen
history book fire and blood
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as showrunners and executive
producers
george r martin will also serve as
executive producer
it's based on george rr martin's
targaryen history book firing blood vol
and on martin's yet unfinished firing
blood volume 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary egg and the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
in other words it covers events from
aegon's conquest to the dance of the
dragons
that's fire and blood vol 1. the atana
released fire and blood vol 2 will
continue from where part 1 ended
with rhaenyra targaryen's son aegon the
third's reign
and will cover blackfyre rebellions the
war with dorne and go all the way to the
mad king
and robert's rebellion attended
targaryen dynasty
but back to aegon's conquest as zarya
stark reminded type lannister in season
2 of game of thrones
aegon was not the only one riding a
dragon during his conquest
it wasn't just aegon riding his dragon
it was rhaenys and with zegna too
rhaenys rode marxists with xenia rhode
vergar
with xenia targaryen was a great warrior
she had a valyrian steel sword she
called dark's sister
arya also revealed to tyvin that visenya
was a heroine of hers
queen with zenith targaryen was the
older sister and wife of aegon the
conqueror
the first lord of the seven kingdoms her
younger sister
rhaenys was married to a gun as well
mesenya was a dragon rider
and rode the dragon begar like her
siblings fazenia possessed the classical
valyrian features
long silver gold hair which she often
braided or bound up in rings
and purple eyes hers was a harsher
beauty than her sister rhaenys
sensual and passionate woman vasania was
also stern
serious and unforgiving some claim that
visenya dabbled in dark sorceries and
played with poisons
visenya was both a dragon rider and a
warrior comfortable in both silk
and in ring mail then garbed as a
warrior she always wielded the valyrian
steel long sword dark sister
visenya was the mother of infamous
maegor targaryen
known as maeger the cruel the third king
of the seven kingdoms
but he died without issue soul of this
subsequent targaryen rulers including
daenerys targaryen
claimed their descent from visenya's
sister rhaenys but let's start from the
very beginning
born on the island dragonstone with
zenya was the eldest child of lordaerian
targaryen
and laid a valley in a valerian her two
younger siblings aegon and rhaenys were
born within a few years following her
birth
since young age visenya trained together
with aegon at arms
and she became a skilled warrior as
expected visenya was fed to her brother
aegon
following valyrian custom however aegon
took their younger sister as a wife as
well
people claimed that he had vet visenya
out of duty and rainy's out of desire
prior to her wedding visenya became a
dragon rider having bonded with the
dragon vagar
when aegon's conquest of the seven
kingdoms began with zenia sailed with
her siblings from dragonstone
while aegon began construction of the
aegon fort wizania subdued house
stockworth
by setting ablaze the roofs of
stockworth after the defeat of house
dark cleaning nagun's first test
isenia claimed the richest of duskendale
swelling the coffers of house targaryen
having conquered a dozen houses and
secured the mouth of the black water
aegon was crowned king at the aegean
fort visenya now a queen placed a
valyrian steel circlet on aegon's head
while their sister rhaenys hailed him as
the new king of all westeros
following the coronation with zhenya
accompanied the targaryen fleet to gull
town
and the vale of iran when the irene
fleet sunk a third of targaryen ships
and captured many more
in a battle in the waters of gull town
where xenia descended from the sky upon
vegar
burning their ships next visenya was
sent to crack law point by aegon
the local lords had learned of the death
of karen thorne
king of the isles and the rivers at the
burning of herron hall by aegon
so the crack claws submitted quickly to
visenya swearing goats of filthy
visenya took them as her own men and
from that day
forth the lords owed their loyalty
directly to the iron throne
isenia met rainy saigon and the
targaryen hosts that stoney set
from where they raced south there they
met the combined hosts of the reach
and the westerlands in battle visenya
and her siblings fought from dragonback
setting dry grasses and stands of wheat
on the battlefield of fire
with more than 4 thousand men dead from
the fire and tens of thousands wounded
by the flames
the battle became known as the field of
fire mern the ninth gardener
king of the ridge died in battle while
lauren the first lannister
king of the rock fled and bend the knee
giving targaryens the victory
according to legend visenya thanked the
gods that lauren had ridden forth to
face the targaryens
when she saw casterly rock as she
believed that dragonflame would not have
been able to dishearten the lannister
king
if he had remained inside the rock
visenya had taken an arrow in the
shoulder
during the field of fire but soon
recovered
following the surrender of king loren
the three targaryen siblings parted ways
once more
but met soon again at the banks of the
trident where they evaded the host of
torrent stark
king in the north after taurean bend the
knee visenya aparted from her siblings
and returned to the vale
where how serene had strengthened their
defenses
a strong host had been positioned at the
bloody gate
however visenya bypassed these hosts by
flying up to the area upon the guard's
back
she landed in the courtyard where she
was met by ronald ren
the young king of mountain and whale
ronald's regent and mother lady shararin
surrendered the erie to visenya
visenya fought alongside her siblings in
the first dornish shore
which lasted from 4 ac to 13 ac
after rainies died in dorne in 10ac with
zhenya and aegon grieves stricken at her
death
set every castle keep and hold fast in
dorne ablaze at least once
with the exception of sunspear they also
placed bounties on the heads of the
dornish lords
although half a dozen and more of those
lords were killed by assassins
only two of the killers lived to collect
their reward
in retaliation the dornish lords hired
cat's paws themselves
visenya and her escort were once
attacked in king's landing
and she cut the last would-be assassin
down herself
the dark sister vizani also
single-handedly saved her brother
husband and king a gun from assassins
when the conqueror argued that his
guards were still sufficient for his
protection
with zenya drew dark's sister before his
guards could react
she had caught aegon's cheek pointing
out to him that his guards were slow and
lazy
this event led to the birth of the
king's guard with any model the valves
of the kingsguard upon the valves of the
night's watch
and she selected the first seven members
herself reigns's death in dorne in
tennessee shattered the health of her
son amy's
and people began to doubt as to whether
he would live
as visenya had not yet gotten pregnant
by aegon despite more than a decade of
marriage
some had come to believe that she was
barren and even went as far as to
suggest to aegon that he should take a
new wife
although many young women were presented
to aegon he refused to voice his opinion
on the matter
in 11ac with zenya announced she was
pregnant with a son
and the next year she gave birth to
aegon's second son
maegor on dragonstone vizagnia raised
maegor on dragonstone
and gave him her valyrian steel sword
dark sister
as the name day present when the boy
turned 13.
in 23ac aeneas first child princess
rhino was born shortly after maeger
turned 12
zenia proposed a betrayal between her
son maegor and reina
to settle the issue of the royal
succession as reina's birth had sparked
the discussion about who was the next in
line behind
anes his own daughter or his brother
however this never happened visenya's
relationship with aegon which had never
been a warm one
grew more distant when aegon in 35
ac had the aegon fort torn down so they
could start building the red keep
visenya was left in charge of the
construction in his history search
maester gildane states
that it was suggested that court that
aegon had left with zany at king's
landing
so that he would not have to endure her
presence on dragonstone
when aegon died both with zenia and
maegor were present
as his body was cremated and aenes the
first targaryen was crowned
aeneas gifted maegor with blackfyre
saying he was more fit to wield it
visenya targaryen voiced the opinion
that tanis was unfit to rule
claiming that by giving blackfyre to
maegor aenes had admitted that he lacked
the strength to rule
in 39ac visenya sunmeiger shocked the
realm by taking a second wife
and married dally's hair away the
outrage that followed resulted in maegor
being sent
into exile izani was president the next
year at the wedding of king aenes's
children princess rhino to prince
aegon at the feast that followed the
ceremony king genius named aegon prince
of dragonstone
the title which had previously belonged
to maegor
bizenya left the feast in protest and
returned to dragonstone upon vergar
singers claimed that the moon turned red
as they passed it
reigns died in dorne before the end of
aegon's reign
and a few years after aegon's death
their bastard had brother orys died
after an attempted conquest of dorne
meaning that visenya was the last
surviving member of the conquest
generation of targaryens
she continued to exert political
influence during the reign of fagon's
successor
rhaenys's son ain is the first who
proved to be a vehicling
and was totally overwhelmed when the
faith militant uprising broke out
and fled from king's landing to
dragonstone the stress of the uprisings
caused aenes to fall gravely ill
and with zany was called in to try to
heal him with her arcane knowledge of
potions
for a time manis actually seemed to
recover but the news came that his son
and daughter were besieged at crakehole
his health drastically worsened again
some suspect that visenya poisoned her
nephew
although others point out that he did
seem to be recovering
even those who suspect she killed him
debate her motivations
some think it was a cynical power grab
for her son maegor
while others think she did it for the
good of the targaryen dynasty
as xenis had proved to be a failure and
incapable of resisting the faith
militant
within hours of anus's death visenya
flew to pentos to retrieve maegor from
exile
they returned with vagar maegor riding
his father's dragon valerian
and an army of several hundred
sellswords maegor then proclaimed
himself a king
ahead of anus's surviving sons and
daughters
usurping the throne and proceeded to
reclaim king's landing
visenya accompanied him to king's
landing where she challenged anyone who
denied mangor's right to rule
which resulted in a trial of seven
between maegor and the warrior sons
although severely injured maegor was the
only survivor
vasani ultimately died late in maegor of
the crow's reign from a sudden illness
maegor lost a key ally and the guard was
left riderless
not long afterward all the great houses
finally turned against maegor openly
and he died on the iron throne itself
visenya was cremated as per targaryen
custom
her bones and ashes were interred beside
those of her brother husband king aegon
the first targaryen
that's the story of queen with zenia
targaryen the warrior sister and wife of
fagon the conqueror with whom she had a
son maegor the cruel
along with her siblings visenya played a
key role in the targaryen invasion of
westeros
her most notable action being the
single-handed conquest of the vale of
iren
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace